Hãy hôm nay, hôm nay, mẹ mẹ mẹ ngay ngay khu chăm hai mi so,
có con cạnh sẽ đổi chào con hành thành phố chiming,
không cạnh sẽ hình sự đã chế phá đừng dây hành động mức bóng dành
một bóng dành động bản nội để tốt chức đổi nội kêu xã hội đàn,
nằm cưỡng đại tài sản của mình dành.
Cái đổi chào bà đồ, mẹ ngay ngay ngay khu chăm hai nội,
vô hành lâm, xin lâm, mục miền chiến tranh tảm đối tụ.
Châu phần chung mấy tầy, thành phố chiming,
thành lập công ty của phần đối tư mô bản nội xanh wâm,
chút xử tại phần tình xanh, chứ đỏ,
lâm tùng đồ hành mô công ty dịch của đoạn lượng.
Tìm nhằm kê vì chẳng sức bản đập,
làm chuyện xanh mua hình hô bản nội,
tức chất là dùng vật đồng giá cây bệnh tức tục tụ chức đoạn
nội tây trái pháp đột.
Đáng chú ý, các đồng mô bản nội chỉ là vỏ bọc nền vật tức má
hạt đập đoạn nội tùy hệ.
Tức tế, công ty không thình tản thình mô khỏe mộ cho chung mộ mà chỉ thỏe tận ăn chiếm phần chăm,
từ hai milen phần chăm đến năm năm phần chăm, chân số tình đoạn đột.
Mà giá, kết hảm quan phải đông phía thần định vô xe lên đến hảnh chục chữ đồng,
không hảnh lại nếu không đoạn được mộ.
Tự năm nay nhé khu chăm ra mô đến nay,
công ty này đã ký khóa bốn chăm đến nhan chân hộ bộ mô bản nội.
Đói được không một chân tý đồng và tương đợi phòng mây yang đing ra một tý đồng.
Con cố tầy liệu, chân cú tụ thật lúc,
có tăng kánh xe đu trà đá ra có định hệ tự rù ăn,